okay are we okay too
yes please good evening everybody um
thank you for joining us this evening um
welcome to watchful district council's
remote review committee meeting
um welcome to anyone that's watching by
the live stream on youtube
agenda item number one is apologies for
absence
we have none
agenda item number two is substitute
members
there are none
item number three non-members attending
um sonia do you have a list of those
that you could read out
yes of course we have counselors fd
wooden belton row and williams
lovely thank you sonya gender
item number four which is minutes of the
meeting held on the first of december
2020.
um my thanks to um councillor sperin for
chairing that meeting in my absence
um are members happy for me to sign
those minutes
agreed i think yep there's agreements
and lots of thumbs up so
i'm assuming from that they're happy if
you if anybody's unhappy
please raise your hand counselor mrs
mason
um i'm not unhappy i had raised my hand
on the um
other item on non-members attending
but you obviously didn't notice mr
chairman so
if i could revert back to that i'd just
like to some clarification
um the review committee conventionally
um i'm glad we've got the legal officer
here i'm sure she can clarify this
um does not allow portfolio holders
onto it yet we have portfolio holders as
non-members attending and
then normally that would only happen if
they were presenting a report
as far as i'm aware they're not could
could someone clarify
and confirm that we are uh operating
within the constitution
the whole idea is that it's the review
committee can scrutinize the work of
portfolio holders so obviously they're
not allowed to be on the committee
thank you council mrs mason um angela
law
is that a question that you can answer
for us please
i mean they they are visiting members of
this committee and that is allowed they
are not sitting as official members of
this committee
thank you thank you
moving on to agenda item number five
which is to receive declarations of
interest
including any whipping declarations
um i i believe i may have to declare an
interest in the one of the items is only
briefly mentioned
under the um key decisions document
regarding the
crown hill toilet by virtue of the fact
that i am a member of brady town council
i don't know if that's correct or not
but i think it should be
um councillor robin dre thank you uh mr
chairman
i'm also a member of ireland town
council but i'd like
to um declare an interest in as much as
um
i'm acquainted with a member of the
public who are interested in the
possible
lease for those premises so i think that
i should declare an interest for that
purpose
thank you councillor councillors perry
thank you chairman uh again like some of
the other colleagues on this committee
i'm also a member of rayleigh town
council like yourself
thank you councillor sperry any other
declarations at all
it doesn't appear to be councillor
member of the freddie town council
thank you councilman
okay so moving on to item number six
this evening
which is the covid19 lessons learned
report
um and we we're here to consider the
report of the acting managing director
actually not the acting managing
director any longer with a further
report to consider
um there are there are several
attendees here preceding for this item
um
before i hand over to angela hutchins on
this item i wanted to start by putting
on record
um my thanks and i'm sure the thanks of
members of the review committee
um to the staff at watchful district
council who continue to work
tirelessly under very difficult and
exceptional circumstances
i believe and quite rightly so
that there are many critical and key
workers who deservedly receive
public recognition and thanks for the
hard work that they continue to
undertake
during these difficult times and also
believe that there are other critical
and key workers who unfortunately don't
always
receive the same thanks in recognition
for their hard work
and i personally feel that often council
staff around the country
and more importantly here at rochford
district council
are somewhat overlooked um i think it's
fair to say that and i'm sure that
members would agree that councils are
operating under extremely challenging
circumstances and it's thanks to
to the staff and officers that at
watchful district council and their
continued hard work
and commitment that all of us within the
district continue to experience
minimal disruption to our day-to-day
lives
in respect of council managed activities
and operations
so um so many thanks to you all the only
reason i'm mentioning that now is
because
i didn't want it to come across as an
afterthought um counselor mrs mason i
can see you've raised your hand
thank you uh mr chairman it's just
before we go on to the report i've just
got a
query of protocol um i'm having to
use the um council website
out of my phone and sorry
i'm having to use the council website
and the report that we're discussing
today is mark
confidential i'm not sure if it's on the
website in
error or if alternatively it's marked
confidentially in
error as far as i'm aware we didn't make
confidential reports public
but um just a matter of uh
to be cleared up before we proceed if
you don't mind
okay thank you for making us aware of
that councilman
um andrew is that something that i can
refer over to you
yes if i clarify by all means chairman
yes the watermark
uh should have been removed before
publication so apologies um to the
committee that that didn't happen
uh the document uh had it been uh
confidential would have been on pink
uh it is not thank you okay thank you
for clarifying that um angela to be
honest i'm gonna hand over to you now
anyway um thank you for for drafting the
report
um which i hope members have all had a
chance to read um
in usual style angela if i could ask you
just to brief members
make them aware of any points that you
specifically want to highlight to them
and then answer any questions i will
just let members know that
i i did submit some questions to angela
ahead of the meeting
um i didn't actually realize angela how
many questions i had actually submitted
to
so i am very grateful for you um for
answering all of those prior to the
meeting
and i there there are a couple that i
know you've asked me to to mention to
other officers here this evening which i
will do but
um andrew if i can hand over to you
thank you um chair members um
it is fitting that uh this report comes
before you
on the day that we enter into national
lockdown
back in september i prepared the first
report which i said would be
in a series of reports and this
follow-up is the second
it is inevitable that there will be more
um i have tried to capture all the
feedback provided by members
um at the committee back in september
whilst at the same time
uh um keeping the report legible um
and members will understand that the
report is of course
not exhaustive thank you chairman for
your kind words earlier and i'm grateful
to colleagues
from across the council who've assisted
me with the preparation of this report
and the members of leadership team who
are here this evening to answer
questions that members will have
chairman if i may i'd like to echo your
thanks and take the opportunity to thank
all members of staff who have worked and
continued to work so hard
to deliver the council's response to
cobit 19.
we are a very small authority and i'm
proud to say that we've held our own
compared to others over the last
nine months and as we prepare for the
most challenging months yet to come
the staff of the council will continue
to work together with colleagues from
health
blue light services faith and community
sectors
local and central government and of
course the military to
um beat covet 19. i'm quite sure that
there are any number of things that we
could have done better
um and in the spirit of continuous
improvement all constructive feedback is
welcome
um this document um the outbreak
response plan is
is now in uh is live and we are working
towards it
um we're in the we're back in national
lockdown so we
we are not quite where we were in april
because we
know more uh we're better rehearsed and
we're better prepared than we were in
april
but this time it is more complicated for
us as we are
managing logistics of testing and
vaccination as we play our part
in the national roll out of those
programs
but lessons continue to be learned and
we will continue to report um to this
committee for as long as the committee
sees
fit um there are the report is lengthy
um
and i have hopefully organized it in a
way so that it is
as legible as possible and i will defer
to
colleagues from across leadership team
to answer some specific questions
um but chairman i think if i could
perhaps just leave it there
thank you angela um members usually i
would straight away ask if anybody had
any questions as i did mention that
i i did raise a few questions quite a
few questions actually
um to angela um ahead of the meeting
um and a couple of them she has asked me
to refer them to her colleagues if
members wouldn't mind i'm just going to
ask a couple of those now and then i
will
revert back to two other members for
their questions
um this is a question for um dong tribe
actually
um dawn 3.4 of the report i asked angela
um about the reasoning behind a third
party company
um carrying out the activities that are
mentioned in that report
um and to be honest angela has given me
quite a comprehensive answer
um but she has finished it this evening
by just saying that um outsourcing
solution
don tribe can speak more on this item
this evening i just wondered if you
could
perhaps just touch on that for us yeah
i think this is is this um where you're
talking about the
the hybrid mail that's correct that's
right yes
sorry um yeah so so the hybrid mail
is something we have actually done in
the past but on a very small scale
actually
um and we have thought about we should
be actually doing a lot more of this
hybrid now that now when when kobe
happened we realized that there are
quite a number of um printing jobs and i
think they are
they have been put into this report
about what they are it needs to have
some staff
interaction into actually printing and
enveloping so we we've had a look at
some external help in being able to do
that remotely so basically what it will
be
is that in word which is the easiest way
of doing it
you'll literally be able to where you've
got your letter you've composed your
letter you'll be able to click it
and you'll be able to then send it off
to a third party who will post
post it for you not unusual a lot of
councils are already doing it and we've
taken advice from those councils
and under a framework procurement we've
gone through that process
we will be saving money by doing that um
with our franking potentially um we
think we're going to be saving around
about ten thousand pounds in our current
print um sorry postage uh budget
and there'll be some obviously some
other soft sort of savings as well
there'll be some staff savings
there'll be some um savings on our paper
envelopes and we just think this is
quite a viable thing to do
and given that people are at home um
when we actually do set this up
they'll be able to simply click the
button from from where they are and be
able to print it for a third party
so we won't need to have staff on site
to actually do that printing for them
okay lovely thank you um dawn whilst
you're
unmuted if i can just ask you a couple
of other questions just
that angela pointed me in your direction
yeah um just i wonder if you could just
provide members with an update
on the um voip voip
the system um
[Music]
it was jude i think it's scheduled to
the 11th of january
um and angela has mentioned this is a
new contract which replaced the existing
switchboard contract
and just said that you would perhaps be
able to
update members a little bit more on that
yep yep absolutely can
um yes
um which is a new telephone system and
we've been working on this project for a
few months now if something that was
brought forward
that we were always going to do wasn't
going to be until next year we're at the
point now where
we the officers have had training um
and we are able to phone out
on our laptop so which is called a soft
phone we're able to phone out to people
we're not quite at the point yet where
we can
accept calls that's the next the next
stage that we are
we are working on um what we have to do
is migrate our current telephone numbers
so that we can retain those so that we
didn't have to have new telephone
numbers that
we'd had to advertise for obviously the
public to phone into so
we've retained our telephone numbers but
we're reliant on a third party our
current
third third-party contractors to
actually help our new provider
to actually migrate those numbers across
it's been a little bit tricky
i will say and the 11th of january
we thought and we were hoping that we
would be able to go completely live in
the 11th january
but because they haven't been able to
provide us with engineers
that have been able to do the migration
we're now having to push that back to
the end of january
and so you know we are reliant on on the
current provider to actually
give us some some resources to be able
to do that we are pushing back on them
and i've had a conversation with the
project team today um and so yes
that's where we are but we have actually
rolled it out so that we are able to
actually make telephone calls from our
from our laptops ourselves
and that again um and i have discussed
it with a couple of other members
actually
that that we will have savings and
potential savings on that on the
telephone cities
is around 20 000 on my current telephone
budget and the uh the contract we're
actually on a framework
so the framework is a two-year um plus
two years should we should we want to
continue with the current provider
who are actually ring sentry who are
central who are a major
leading telephone operator
okay lovely thank you so by the time the
next report comes out hopefully that
will all be in place and
and hopefully staff would have got used
to that now yes
yeah okay and one last quick question
before i go to members for yourself don
um 3.27 of the report we're talking
about
laptops and i asked angela if all
laptops had now been delivered and if
any more were needed or ordered
just wondered if you could clarify that
uh yes we've offered we've offered rdc
council laptops to to all members um and
uh as far as i know those that have
wanted to have them have now been
been rolled out um in the beginning of
covid it was a little bit of an issue
and i think we've gone over that before
was
you know with us trying to order them we
had staff that needed them
to work off-site and we we had members
but i think now
we have rolled them out but if if there
is anybody who
didn't in the beginning say that they
would like to have a laptop when they
were offered then please come back to me
or to
to ikea and we will absolutely um talk
you out and give you an idc laptop if
that's what you would require
lovely thank you don um i'll let you go
for the moment
um okay good evening uh councillor
wilkinson
can you hear me
i can't hear you councillor wilkins and
i don't know about them is
can you hear me that better yeah sorry i
sat on the sat on the button
um so just picking up from what dawn
tribe said i've had a problem with this
laptop this is my personal laptop and
the sound's not been working too well
so i did actually ask for council one
because there's been a couple of
meetings i've not been able to take part
in so
i don't know if you could um add my name
please dawn to the list of those needing
them i
appreciate it um
chairman moving to the report um i echo
entirely
um the not just the sentiments but the
words that you said as well
um and i i have got a couple of concerns
regarding the report
the report but i want to make it clear
they are regarding the reports
and this is no way me pointing fingers
at the council because i don't think
that's fair i do accept the fact
that this pandemic has been
like none other that any of us have
lived through and i recognize that
my concern is actually going to echo
something i said the last time this
report came to this committee
and i think that it's i'm just going to
try and think of the correct word here
because i'm not going to say it's not
truthful i don't mean that
at all i i think it's economical should
we say with some of the
the the issues that the council has
faced uh
and the way in which it's it's dealt
with it um
and those are the issues that i would
like to pick up if i may
and this is not a criticism on the
council it's just a criticism really on
the report i suppose
um the item three
talks about the printing of documents
now
i was very pleased to hear what dawn's
just said to you
um because this was an issue the
the the the item itself and the reports
basically says yes they didn't do it
but as soon as they could they you know
they intended to it was not
a true representation of what actually
happened what actually happened and i
did highlight this last time
that we were having at the time at least
three
group leader meetings per week every
single week
and every single one of those meetings i
highlighted to the then
managing director and the then leader of
the council know that neither of whom
are in their the current positions that
the council
instead of continuing with its practice
of
posting letters to neighbors for
planning consideration
um when the whole nation was being told
to stay at home it decided to post a
sign outside the relevant address
thereby
nobody seeing it now i raised this time
and time and time time again
um and was told no we're not going to
change not going to change i said
in fact mr scrutten's words were it's a
nicety that we don't have to do
um those were his words uh at no
point at no point did either the then
leader or then managing director say to
me
this is only a temporary thing don't
worry about it once we get this up and
running it'll be back in place which is
what the report
tends to imply to me there was a point
blank refusal so i don't think that
part of the report is representative of
how
this council performed in relation to
the printing of documents and i accept
and recognize why
the managing director now has included
it in there because i raised it last
time and
it's made she made reference to that but
i still don't think it's representative
to what actually happened at the time
the next point i'd like to talk about is
emergency planning which is another
area i mentioned at the last meeting um
that i said that in my my opinion
emergency planning
was woefully inefficient um
now it's interesting to read the report
because it says
at paragraph 3.6 that the top
national risk identified for pandemics
nationally was identified as a pandemic
influenza
now accepting i don't have a medical
degree i don't think there's a huge
amount of difference between pandemic
influenza and what we're currently
suffering and i certainly don't think
that if we did have a pandemic influenza
the government's reaction will be any
different to what it currently is in
other words
lockdown everybody work from home so
with that in mind
if you then have to ask the question
well exactly what emergency planning was
there
for pandemic influenza because this was
identified
nationally as the top risk so what did
we have in place
and the reason i ask that is because the
answer to me would appear as though we
didn't have anything in place because if
we did it would work seamlessly
for covid the fact that viruses are
different doesn't mean to say that the
strategy we would take as a council
would be different
and i don't think that's representative
either in any way
and it even says at paragraph 3.18 it
became clear
that the council's switchboard hardware
and software was incompatible for remote
use
how do we get to that stage if we were
planning for pandemic influenza
in our emergency planning we should have
had something for remote usage but we
didn't
um paragraph 4.9 talked about what went
well
very valuable part of the report what
what about what didn't work
so well that's not in the reports what
about the identified areas
that didn't work well and the reason i
think this is vitally important is
i'm not going to ask this question
because i know it's a fact i know this
council wants to learn
from the good things and the not so good
things that happened
during this pandemic so that we can
improve and move forward how we ever
going to learn
unless we can admit failings unless we
can put our hands up and say
you know what we didn't do this as well
as we should and i don't think this
report says that
there's one other thing i'd like to
mention as well and and i don't this
isn't
even mentioned in the report and this is
something i would like
to ask if possible if this could be
taken forward
to form part of our newly formed
emergency planning or
whatever's going to come out from this
and that's staff and member welfare
now at the beginning of this pandemic
the same week we went into national
lockdown there was an investment board
meeting which took place in the chamber
at the civic suite
within days after that and forgive me
because i can't remember exactly how
this happened but i think it was through
rumor mill you know jungle drums
whatever you want to say
it became known that another counselor
who i will not name
um from another from not from my group
had become unwell
there was a suggestion that that
counselor potentially
was suffering the the symptoms of the
coronavirus
this was hushed to say the least um
the particular member didn't have a test
now that's probably down to the
processes that were in place at the time
but that was never communicated to
members
it was never communicated to staff as
far as i'm aware
it should have been communicated to all
members
who are present at that meeting and
officers who are present to that meeting
a member has displayed symptoms similar
to coronavirus
you may want to consider isolating you
may want to consider your friends and
family if you've got a vulnerable met
friends and family you may want to
consider getting testing that was not
done
that i'm afraid is a failing that should
have been done
and it was it was hushed up at the time
and i would respectfully ask
that in any report that moves forward
from this that
that is included as a policy decision
that this council will now do
and it makes it policy that we have to
do um
and i think i'll leave it there if i may
i just want to make it clear chairman
that that is
i hope it's clear i'm not picking holes
what the council has done
i just think the report is not balanced
enough because
yeah we've done some great things but
there are some other areas that are not
so good and i don't think report
covers those as well and how we're going
to learn unless we do thank you chairman
okay thank you councillor wilkinson um
just
um going back to you your first point um
dawn
have you made a note that council will
consider may require the use of a
council laptop yeah i do have that yes
and you'll be in touch with him
regarding that yep
lovely thank you thank you um council
wilkinson
your point regarding 3.6 of the report
is actually something i raised with
angela earlier today um angela i don't
know if you've got your response to me
to hand because actually your answer to
me was
was quite informative i wondered whether
or not that may be useful
for members to hear that um yes chairman
um i think the important thing to
understand here
is in relation to the national risk
register
um which cascades um across the whole of
the uk
response and and through the essex
resilience forum through to us
as part of our responsibilities under
the civil contingencies act
um so when um pandemic influenza has
been on the
uh risk register previously it's been in
the context of things like stars and
avian flu
so both of which are epidemiologically
very different viruses
to covet 19 and
the impacts which were primarily linked
to the health sector
so our corporate risk register includes
um and deals with mitigations in the
event that staff and resources
are negatively impacted by seasonal flu
and variations there are thereof
but the scale uh and speed
of covert 19 and including its mutations
is unprecedented
and the fact that it's not localized but
global also means
that all the rules effectively have been
rewritten so
the question was around why we weren't
prepared for it
my response is is that we were prepared
for it insofar as the infrastructure was
in place
to support a uh a sub-regional uh
and national response through the local
resilience forums and through the local
and sorry and through the uk government
response but um
nobody uh fully understood the impact of
this
pandemic back in march april um
of last year and arguably uh they are
still
learning today so um i i
have to push back and say that it wasn't
a lack of preparation that everything
would
not have gone seamlessly um because
we have practiced we had business
continuity plans in place
for managing um pinches in and
fluctuations in staff
um and resource management
we did not have a plan in place for the
complete decant of the entire office in
less than 10 days which is what we
we had to do um when national lockdown
came
into into place um and i
take the point in relation to um
reporting of of illnesses and i can't
comment
on the situation that counselor
wilkinson has articulated because i
don't
know anything about that but what i can
say is at the beginning of the
pandemic um things like reporting
uh contact tracing uh and isolation
hadn't even been thought of at that
point and so it was still very much in
its early stages and what we were doing
was and continue to do
is to respond using information provided
to us from
government um and from the um
colleagues in public health england
through the essex resilience forum who
provide us with the information
to provide a coordinated response across
the whole of greater essex
so we as rochefort district council have
a unified approach along with colleagues
across the entire
public sector to make sure that we're
responding in in exactly the same way
um if chairman if i can come back in
relation to the the point around the
planning consultation letters
apologies if um the in elegant drafting
in paragraph
3.1 has set hairs running it's certainly
not my intention
um the reference to temporary meant that
it was um
it it's not a situation which subsists
at this point it was for a limited time
period only
i accept um because i have no reason to
doubt any
conversations that may or may have not
had happened with the
um previous managing director but
the fact remains that it wasn't a a
decision that was taken
um and that still subsists it is in fact
actually one for a limited period of
time and that's what i meant by the use
of the word temporary
thank you um council wilkinson i can see
you're indicating to come back
very briefly yeah just very briefly
thank you very much chair
um angela thank you for clearing that up
regarding the pandemic influenza and i
apologize because uh
i will learn until the day i die and i
didn't realize the difference between
the two
um uh illnesses that's the first thing
the second thing is um i think i mean
i've understood you the member of staff
that i was referring to
that at the time that happened
nationally we were being told
um to inform people we'd be in contact
with so that
was in place i accept the fact that as a
as an authority may not have known about
it so that's not critical of the
authority
i i would like that to be policy moving
forward
but we all knew um at the time that
the because the government was telling
us uh you know you must inform people
you must do this must do that so
everybody that was aware of that
particular person's illness knew that
everybody should have been told
um at the time and the final thing was
oh yes the printing of the letters yes
and i do i do i accept what you're
saying regarding that thank you very
much
thank you council wilkerson um andrew
did you want to come back on that tour
no nothing further thank you chairman
andrew just whilst
we were touching on this subject would
it be fair to say with regards to
planning because i did have
some concerns about the planning that
that was in place
do you feel that um government
um demands and and guidelines
did impact on how well prepared
the council could be because my my
thoughts are that you could plan
as much as you possible but if a short
notice you're being asked to
do this meet this criteria achieve this
how did you do you feel that impacted on
on how the
council was able to respond um very very
much so so
our emergency planning um uh is
um historically has been linked around
as i say business continuity so it's
about dealing with temporary
um losses of staff and or resource so
temporary risks that happen and whether
that's because
uh it's a natural disaster like flooding
or it's an i.t
outage or there is a uh you know if
there was a
an incident at the airport for example
that that would
um have a a sudden unexpected
uh and tangible impact but that was was
temporary in nature
and the whole point around um emergency
planning
is that you stand something up you go
into emergency recovery mode you deal
with the situation and you push
put things back to normal as quickly as
possible
and the whole whole of emergency
planning and every uh resilience forum
across the country
has been working on that basis what is
so different
with uh the the with copic 19 is that we
are nine months on and we're still not
at the end of it
so that the the emergency uh continues
um and it fluctuates uh as some
as new things uh um come and go and we
we are
as a an entire nation um learning
um as the epidemiology and the science
um evolves
and and as we understand more and more
about
uh not only how the disease uh is uh
transmitted but how people
um respond to it and the impacts of it
in
in terms of individual health and and uh
traits and
um amongst particular demographics so
um certainly at the very beginning of
the
uh pandemic when um we were all just
washing our hands because that was
what all we were told to do uh we were
following guidance
from government there was a lot of
misinformation a lot of
information that couldn't be
corroborated um and
lots of opinion being offered about uh
and you'll remember
um the uh the news was full of pictures
of
um china and italy and it didn't seem to
have
uh really resonated here what are we
when i look back on it now i can see
that we stood up
um as part of the a as part of the essex
resilience forum
a strategic coordinating group was stood
up by the chief constable
uh with partners from across the entire
system and we began to plan
our response to this emerging threat
and i think that we have tacked along
government guidance
as it's come along we've challenged
where we've needed to
we've escalated where we've needed to um
but um why working across administrative
boundaries
um we've we've coped as well as we can
do but to a certain extent
it is always going to to be reactive
okay thank you angela um councillor
ahoy thank you
chairman um i've got a few
bits to say i'll just go through them
all to start with it and um some are on
the report and some are on the um
what i would call the confidential
report afterwards as well which i now
know is not confidential
um i just want to start with the and i
don't allow you at the point
um but i there are very
few business continuity plans that i've
seen that don't include loss of an
office
and they would include working from home
in the short term at least
and the ability to do so i accept that
this was not in our plan because it
clearly wasn't
i wouldn't expect us to have a
continuity plan for what we've had
that's
fine i understand that it's very very
outside of my imagination that this
would have happened but
i can't i don't understand why we didn't
have a plan which included the closure
of an office
i've queried this in other committees
and i've been assured there was
i understand that it might have been a
temporary laws of office maybe for a
month until you get up and running
somewhere else
but that would include working from home
and not i clearly can't see anything
of that sort which we've been able to
take from one part of our
business continuity or emergency
planning and put it in place here
um that's what i'm going to say on the
point going forward i'm sure we've
learned from that
um on the report itself and
bear with me because again as long as
i'm on one screen on the report i'm
just going to go through a few quick
points on the the report which is for
noting
one is which maybe you can come back to
me afterwards one is the great wakering
amenity
vehicle can you say what is the reason
that is not possible
when it's not possible to reinstate that
because that's always been quite
important
um okay sorry council ahoy if i can just
let um would that be something angela
you would answer
you to be honest once and then come back
afterwards it'd be a lot easier i think
that way
uh well yeah but if there's too many i
don't want um officers
the main confidential one there's only
three on this enough just got a few
careers on the actual
three short ones that's fine yeah the
next one is
and i've raised this with um angel
already about this one
which is 3.29 i've said just because
we're learning
as we go along with 365 i actually use
it within my business as well
and i know other people do doesn't mean
that we know everything
we've just learned what we need to learn
to get by so
i really do believe we still do need
training it's not out of date
you still need training because there
are things members will not know
on that and but nothing that's quite
important
to that previously um
and then finally on the actual report
itself it's talking about the impact of
of staffing staff finishes cost savings
pressures on stuff
um it's slightly outside of this but i
just want to raise it because it's come
to my attention today
that one of the things which i had
thought had worked well
um and i thought was still working well
was the administration of grants
via the council from central government
to businesses i know the first lot of
grants went out quite well
um there's further a lot of grants which
i understand
of stuck are no grants for businesses
which are currently closing have been
closed since november that these are
stuck around second of
december and no grants have have been
issued
since then and their business is waiting
for november and december grants
and i just want that cleared up about
where we are with
that and i suspect that may be down to
resourcing which is 0.8
on on that report they're the the main
points on there then i've got some on
the confidential local outbreak response
plan
so i don't know if they want to be
answered first as you suggested chairman
okay thank you um council hook way
um with regards to your um
oh sorry council ahoy um with regards to
your question regarding the
vehicle at great wakering um this is
something i raised with angela earlier
and she she has responded to me
um but she did refer possibly to
um marcus you've been able to maybe
address this
this query slightly better is that okay
yes yeah thank you um okay i can do so i
mean it's um
we were keen to sort of um continue the
services we could i mean originally
it stopped um due to the fact that we
felt that um social distancing couldn't
really be practiced
and and therefore the risk of transition
of kobe but there was a high risk
between those uh cueing to to um deposit
waste and also that the staff would help
load
i mean it it's not an easy uh service to
run at the best of times so you're
offering quite close quarters
and so the the risk assessments
undertaken by suis indicated they felt
that it was too high risk to continue
at that time um we did speak some about
whether it could be done in a different
way and
we're willing to resource that uh as
well if need be you know to address
the difference it wasn't a financial
situation it's just there seems to be no
practical way of of doing so safely i
think from
their conclusion to the risk assessments
they undertook uh and um i mean
certainly other
councils that undertake a similar
service such as baseline and tendering
come to the same conclusion
because we actually did ask if um if
sues wouldn't do it we did then
go to other suppliers to say would
someone else be willing to do this
um and again um we had one that suggests
but then again when we actually pressed
on the the the ability to manage the
risk and demonstrate they could
manage risk of covered um um
successfully
they they couldn't produce a
documentation that i felt that we were
that we felt was satisfactory so
that's where we are at the moment the
conclusion is that we thought at the
present time
we cannot undertake that service safely
just due to the risk of covered
thank you thank you marcus
um angela with regards to training which
um council la hoya raised um obviously
is mentioned in the report
did you come back on that i don't know
if you wanted that's something that
would still be considered
you're on mute sorry andre apologies um
yes so the original training which had
been i i
should which have been prepared is
probably now out of date but certainly
um i know that um dawn is happy to look
at that again and one of the things we
have talked about
is identified continuing support
when necessary so that piece of work
will will take place
um chairman if i can just come back on
the
business continuity plans piece uh about
the loss of an office
so um loss of i.t loss of staff and loss
of an office was part
of the um of our business continuity
plans
but what we didn't anticipate was having
to decant an entire office
uh you know the whole of south street
plus um colleagues over at the civic
suite so
we went not just from losing an office
to losing all of our space and requiring
everybody to remote
uh remote work so um that that was the
the
that's the difference really i think
between the the
event that we had planned for and the
eventuality and the practicality the
reality of what we actually had to to
deal with
um the the staff costing peace in
relation to
sorry the to to grant business grant
administration
um if i could ask um chairman um naomi
lucas to speak to that point
of course naomi
okay lovely thank you thank you
yeah um we certainly have been um
paying out um grants um including the
closed
grant scheme um since the
second national lockdown in uh november
um we've been paying those out steadily
since that point
um the complexity in a number of
different grant schemes has escalated
since the um
well the second uh national lock down
and there and then the tier four
restrictions imposed
on essex after that point um so there's
several different schemes under
operation now including um
a scheme for businesses which were open
but affected by the
the additional restrictions um the
closed scheme which affected businesses
which had to close completely
and then there was an additional
restrictions grant as well which was a
more discretionary element of grant
and there's further schemes that have
been um just announced in the last day
or so which we
the council will also be um seeking to
pay out to businesses
but um yeah i wouldn't like members to
be under the false impression that
there's been a lot of jam in the in the
system we certainly have been
paying out and those grants deadly since
they were introduced
thank you
i think i'll just i don't think um i
would ever agree about the um continuity
plan so i'll leave that there um
on the point of the on the um
so this is the kovid 19 local outbreak
response
plan which is version 1.00
um first paragraph introduction
this kovid 19 local outbreak response
plan is in
intended to operate as a whole council
business continuity plan
in the event there is an increase in
cases of kobit 19 in rocha district
and as part of the council's reasonable
worst case scenario planning
as we approach the winter's flu season
um there's a couple points i'm going to
leave a few of them
they're fairly minor i can raise those
separately um
the the big question i want to go to is
on
page 6.17
and i'll then dart around a little bit
so this just to clarify this is 6.17 of
the actual response plan is it
yeah to address the priorities the
council will take the
action set out below and the first one
is incept the rdc
outbreak response team and associated
meeting schedule
i want to know if this has ever met
and then from that point i can ask or
not ask further questions just to save
time
yeah yes it has met and uh we had a
meeting um our latest meeting just today
okay is that does that meet income like
after the um
essex response forum the resilience
forum
so it it it is linked to that although
there isn't
a particular battle rhythm at as things
currently stand
um the we did not incept the
outbreak and uh response team for the
period of national restrictions during
november
um because um there was
no um increased need to do so at
that time um it was you'll recall
that government approach was that that
would be a um
a fire break for one of a better um term
um as we moved into tier four the tier
four announcement was made on the 19th
of december
um or with effect from the 19th of
december um
i actually think it's the week before as
i've kind of lost track but anyway in
in mid uh early to december um the
um the outbreak response um team uh
convened
uh and again as i say convened this
morning
so it's convened a couple of times i'm
just surprised that
i as a member wasn't aware of it because
the following further down the page it
says that
about the involvement of members and he
said although we won't
you might not share all information with
members because it may be officially
sensitive
but the commit council commits to
transparency transparency
i'm sorry if i have missed it but i have
not seen anything to say that this
team has met even um no no
we have we we um we keep uh um an action
log and notes of the things we discuss
but there's not you know
not minutes as such the um
the things that we are we tend to notify
members of the outcomes of the
of the meetings and if we conclude that
it's um for us in terms of redeployment
for example
we would notify members that way so it's
very much um driven
by the uh actions that we we decide as
part of the
team meeting but i'll take it as an
overall thing rather than take out
little points from this
if i just go with the overall point
which i think is probably would be much
clearer is
that i would consider that is in the
midst of a local outbreak
hence my question has it met we've been
in the top 10 in the country for the for
the numbers
the place i do not want to be i know
holbridge alone has been over 1600 i
think rochefort has pros
has approached 2 000 cases per hundred
thousand
sorry i'm not breathing over a hundred
thousand
um i just
i just can't see what one
i think it might have been appropriate
to tell members that yes we consider
there is a local outbreak and the team
has met
um nothing has come from yeah that's
fine but this is the transparency this
is about telling
members what goes on and this is one of
the frustrations we've had over a number
number of years and also with this also
links back to emergency planning and i
noticed counselor joe mcpherson is going
to speak
and she's also raised this in review
before with emergency planning
about the fact that the councillors are
just left
out of things i assume the leader was
informed that it
met i'm not sure he's on it because it
doesn't say so um
and and this is the point we are we are
at a point where we are
have a massive local outbreak we were
amongst the first in the country to have
such high figures
yet we don't seem to have done much
about it
um i'm not seeing
who is the emergency officer a permanent
member of staff for instance
yes they are um i haven't seen
much of what they're supposed to be
doing happening either i've not seen the
redeployment plan i've not seen
um environment health being a single
point of
liaison testing trace i understand that
there was a press release came out today
that we now test
there's now testing available atom the
mega center
i understood it might have been at south
street but is that also at south street
or just
now
i just think the i'm not sure we're
acting to the report or if the report
is being is being fully implemented it
should be
that's the problem okay i think i think
members are probably
gathering from that that your main
queries about
member involvement um i think angela
could
sorry it's not member involvement it's
about it's
yes member involvement i don't know if
the report is being followed
i can't tell because we don't know i've
got no evidence to show that the report
is being followed at all
that the our outbreak pain i don't know
if that ain't outbreak pain is being
followed
because nobody's telling me if it is or
isn't
okay angela if you could just come back
on that please yes so
um i can i can come back on and explain
that so as you
as you've identified um the um
essex resilience forum meets regularly
at the moment we're meeting
daily information that comes via that
channel
um is official sensitive and therefore
is not something that i am at liberty to
discuss
more widely but communications channels
from the essex resilience forum
have been prepared via the essex chiefs
and
leaders meeting and
councillor neil stock from tendering is
the chairman of that group and he
disseminates information to all members
um as a consequence of that so it has
been agreed that that is the primary
communication channel
um from the essex resilience forum and
the pfcc
um briefs members of parliament direct
so that so the information that you
receive by those channels
is is the information which i'm
permitted to share
the um we are following the outbreak con
response um plan but as i say in
relation to this current situation we've
met for the first time
to discuss the current situation today
and we have talked about
uh testing um as one of the key string
strands that we're talking about the uh
i brief
the um executive uh every single week
um sometimes more than once a week
and the information that i
um send out the briefing i send out to
to members
and also to the public
happens every friday as well and the
version that members receive
very often contains information which is
not shared with the general public
um the uh in relation to
uh testing um the um
the you've the the information relating
to the mega center
is uh in relation to lateral flow
uh device tests which is
a pilot scheme being put forward by
essex county council
and in partnership with our colleagues
at the mega center to provide that venue
that is not the same as
the pcr home test kits
which we are intending to um operate
from south street uh we are um
in the process of standing that up uh
hopefully at some point later on this
week we've been waiting for essex county
council to confirm um
a go live date with us and we're in the
process of doing that but that is
something different
um and that is um and we'll there'll be
communications coming out um in relation
to that as soon as we're able to share
them
thank you angela and just to touch on
that because again this was
something you and i discussed earlier
and i thought your response was was very
good and
and if i can just read that out to you
the operational plan um
is is written and composed by watchful
district council and it's based upon the
response to the first
lockdown and i think as you quite
rightly said it's a living document
which will continue to be updated so
i don't think what we're seeing at the
moment is
set in stone and i think it it's
probably highly likely to change i would
think
from the learning curve that the council
and
members are on yeah if i'm here i would
absolutely agree that nothing should
ever be set in stone
we're learning continuously and i hope
that's the case however i don't
see this report being put into action
and again
i don't see that members are being
informed i mean on page
6.19 17
elected members have an important role
in the event of a local outbreak
as representatives representatives of
their local communities
they are a focal point for provision of
information and provision of support and
encouragement
a local outbreak is likely to cause
widespread spread concern and possible
confusion and disarray
and elected members can pass important
safety information and other advice from
the outbreak response team
to the affected communities all we have
is information we can't
let people know off from the essex
resilience forum
or essex county council press releases
we don't we don't have anything from
roger council
or that or this fault and i think we
should learn from it it doesn't seem to
be very proactive
at all in helping i think and i think
you've probably raised some points that
angela and the team will take away with
them and bear in mind
um possibly moving forward as much as
you possibly can
would that be correct answering saying
that um yes yes of course um the only
thing i would say is that
um part of the essex resilience forum is
that all
organizations give a consistent
communications message
so all of um so we're tied into the
essex
communications group all information um
and assets are cascaded across the whole
of the system uh
in an identical fashion so although it
comes across as an ecc
it may come across as an ecc um
press release actually it's also
emanating from the police and from fire
and from the health service and from the
nhs
and we we are not being proprietary in
um
in in branding them rdc because actually
it's the the consistency of the message
that's key
and by being part of a unified approach
to communications that means that
everybody
across the whole of greater essex gets
the same information
i take the point um from councillor hoy
in relation to
um briefing of the wider membership
um but i can say to you that i have told
you everything that i am able to tell
you
um and um there is no further
information at this stage
that i am uh i can share um and
as frustrating as that might be it is
the nature of
of the of the way in which we are
managing the
pandemic as we go forward um there will
be
greater opportunities for members to
take the community leadership role
certainly in terms of promulgating key
messages around
social distancing and um and
adherence to to rules but as we get into
um the vaccination program in particular
um i will be looking
to uh the elected membership to assist
in in
becoming community ambassadors and
taking that forward as as part of our
response
thank you angela i'm just keen to move
the question on because i can see that
quite a few members
have raised their hands and some have
been waiting quite a while
um so councillor hook wayne
yeah thank you chairman um
the the point i was going to raise has
been touched on by councillor
michael high but
my my point is a little bit more
specific
it's relating to some of the money
that's been cascaded down from central
government
and being allocated to local authorities
to
distribute as parts of the grants
schemes that have been put in place
um now back in
november um the there was a scheme
relating
specifically or aimed at specifically
the hospitality
uh sector um and um
there was the ability for um businesses
to
uh apply for um
the uh the grant funding and i believe
it's uh
it's done on a monthly basis
um and the way that it's managed
is on the basis of um businesses in the
hospitality sector
that have a um a business address that
they pay
business rates on um now
the government scheme um did allow
for businesses uh within that sector
to be able to apply for um grant
grant funding um that didn't have a
business address
but it was a discretionary uh element to
the scheme
and as far as i i'm aware uh
that um this council rochefort council
um this site has decided not to uh
uh use the discretionary element as part
of this scheme
um because if it does i can't find
any information on the council's website
as to
whether it does offer
this funding to businesses that don't
have a
a business address that pays business
rates
do you know the name of the scheme at
all um not off the top of my head but
the thing is that this scheme is uh
current and topical because the
chancellor has announced today the
extension of
this a scheme or a scheme which is very
much similar in relation to
funding up to nine thousand pounds for
businesses going forward
under the current uh lockdown um
situation now my question is
um bearing in mind that we may well be
um in in this lockdown period for much
longer than what we were in november
is the council going to
this time uh implement the discretionary
element
and allow businesses that don't have
business premises
to apply for uh this uh grant funding
now i do have to declare an interest in
this because i obviously have
a business uh which would uh directly be
affected by that but i do not see
why this should prevent me from asking
and posing the question to the council
because there would be many many other
businesses
and individuals who are in a similar
situation um
and bearing mind this is a public
meeting they have the opportunity to
find out
um answers to this particular question
is obviously very relevant because um
there people
are going to be looking to uh seek
assistance
going forward because we're in this uh
for a for a considerable period of time
now
okay thank you i think the first thing
to do there
um sonia if you could know um county
took ways interest i think he
may have not been present when i asked
originally
um at the beginning of the meeting for
notes of interest
um naomi i'm assuming this is a question
that
you're going to address is that correct
thank you chair um so i i believe the
scheme that council liquor is referring
to is what's been referred to as the
open
um scheme and it does get confusing with
the number as i said of different um
schemes that have been launched by the
government over this this period
um it wasn't specifically
aimed at leisure and hospitality um
as the um first scheme was in the first
lockdown which was specifically called
um
sort of leisure and hospitality grant um
but it was aimed at businesses that were
affected by the restrictions but weren't
actually forced to close down so for
example
um restaurants that could only operate
um you know a takeaway service um as
opposed to a sit-in service for it for
for example so um that they were
primarily the businesses that were
targeted through this open scheme
um as council hook grace said there was
quite strong guidance from government
about it being targeted at businesses
that have a
um that were on the ratings list um
and um the council chose to
um implement that scheme in line with
the government guidance which targeted
it at
those businesses on the ratings list
there was an element of discretion
within that scheme
but because we were simultaneously also
launching um
another scheme called the additional
restrictions grant which was
uh aimed at the more discretionary
elements of
the um of the um
of the scheme um we chose to um
yeah target those businesses that
couldn't apply through the open scheme
um to the additional restrictions front
and um
so businesses that weren't necessarily
on the ratings list or for example
um were part of the supply chain for
example
that those businesses were eligible to
apply for that additional restrictions
grant and
and um a number of those businesses have
been successful through that through
that scheme
um in terms of the latest scheme which
government has just announced
again that is targeted at those
businesses on the ratings list and
there's very specific
criteria around what what size of
businesses will be eligible for for
different levels of grants
and we will be putting out some more
communications and guidance
on that particular new scheme in the
next couple of days so i hope
that provides a little bit of clarity
but i do expect that
the number of um different schemes under
different eligibility criteria for them
has made the whole
process um a bit confusing for some but
we have tried to be as clear as we can
in our communications and
on our website in terms of the
eligibility for the different schemes
thank you thank you know me um
councilwood
you can come back if it's it's very
quick because like i said quite a few
members have yet to ask their questions
so i would like to move it forward
yes yes will do um i just um
wondered whether it might be uh possible
for
if there is something that is available
to businesses that don't have a business
address
that need um looking for some financial
help because they are affected by
um the uh the restrictions that uh are
currently in place
that um it's uh it
it should be a bit more promptly
advertised on their website so that
it does seem that it's very difficult to
locate
some of this information so i just ask
that
um that this might be something that
could be advertised a bit better if
that's possible thank you
thank you councillor hookway i i don't
think that's specifically something you
can address
naomi about where it's published
that um thanks chair that um obviously
it's probably
always more we could do differently or
better but i would just say that
um we did send around um the all mem um
sorry all
public communications and briefings at
um
quite promptly at the time advertising
all the different schemes and it was
advertised on the face of the
council's website for example and also
um there was
joint communications again throughout
essex on the on the
availability of the different schemes so
we did make every effort to try and
publicize those as far as possible but
except there's probably always more that
we can do
thank you naomi um i understand um
marcus
did you want to come in on this item or
the
question uh uh only three since senator
uh i can ask
to make contact with council hook way um
to discuss his details and concerns a
bit more in detail tomorrow if there's
any
further information requires thank you
thank you
thanks very much for that um
moving on councillor mcpherson uh thank
you chairman
um page six um i'm drawing
uh members attention to three point two
one and three point two
two um personally i just wanna give some
huge credit to all the staff
who went the extra mile um
and are still going the extra mile being
redeployed
working on sociable hours and also
volunteering with the community hub
it also mentions the positive impact
this has had
on the staff moving forward
um the head of paid service mentioned um
staff willing
assist in the rollout of um i believe
the testing kits um
just need to clarify which ones um i'm
just speaking as someone who volunteered
with the community hub
which i have to say was superbly well
run um
and most recently with the roll out of
the vaccinations
um please could members be invited
to volunteer again i'm quite happy to
stand as most people know
in a high vis in a wet cold car park
um so i'm happy to lend a hand i'm sure
others will be um
if only to take some pressure off of our
staff who have as i said gone the extra
mile
um also on page 11 uh this again will be
something for the um header paid staff
and the pulse surveys mentioned that's
going to be rolled out
now these as most people know are
shorter more frequent surveys so i'm
presuming more will be going out
um i ask because such things as
um compassion fatigue can take a while
to emerge within them
staff during the pandemic um will these
surveys be anonymous and if so
how will you identify the areas um where
there
are issues or where supports needed
thank you chairman thank you council
mcpherson
angela did you just want to come back on
those yes i know you and i touched on
the surveys earlier and you did explain
to me about the survey
yeah so um thank you to councillor
mcpherson
um member volunteers are very much
welcomed out
and uh communication will be coming out
to the whole
elected membership um tomorrow
in relation to the administration of
um pcr testing kits out of south street
um we're just as i said a moment ago
firming up the logistics with
ecc i don't want to give you uh
information that isn't
um factually correct so um we're just
checking on those details and as soon as
we
are clear and the because we're
expecting 5 000 tests to be delivered
and as soon as they
uh we have a delivery date and we know
um
that we're good to go that we will be uh
asking for for volunteers and
and with those committed dates because
we'll want to put together
a rota as quickly as possible so thank
you for that
um volunteering across the membership i
think is uh
something uh that um and across the uh
organization i think is something that
we're we're all very proud to stand
behind and
councilman you're absolutely right in
identifying that vaccination going
forward is likely to be
a large draw and the community support
that was provided for the hub
we're hoping that again we'll rally
round to support
um community vaccination programs going
forward in the in coming weeks
um our staff surveys um we yes the poll
surveys are intended to give that short
sharp intervention to take the
temperature of an organization
um they um the the initial pulse survey
um was anonymous so uh ongoing poll
services would be enormous to encourage
people to
be as frank in their responses as they
feel
that they um that they would like to be
um certainly the first pers
poll survey that we did had a very uh
high response rate so we were very
encouraged by that
um and um i'm conscious of
organizational fatigue i'm conscious
of issues in relating to
mental health and isolation as um staff
continue to
adjust to the difficult conditions that
we're all operating under
and certainly the the design of the next
poll survey something that
hr colleagues and i are working on to
make sure that we
uh give um opportunities for
staff members to identify those and put
in place the mitigations that we can
support them with we do continue to
sign post um with our mental health
first aiders
um the employee assistance program
and pastoral calls which uh myself
and colleagues from hr have been
carrying out and all line managers and
assistant directors take the time
to um to to work with colleagues to make
sure that they
are um that they're doing okay and that
it's
it's okay to to not be okay and
particularly as we come into this next
lockdown and uh many of our staff
are coping with uh school-aged children
at home with um we we are um
have uh revised our list of critical
workers
um who are entitled to send their
children into school
if if the schools are in fact open of
course and we're providing
um letters of support to those working
parents
who would like to take advantage of of
that opportunity
so that's what we will continue to do
thank you thank you chairman thank you
councilman mcpherson
i'm for one grateful my children at home
because i've never been so good at maths
in all my life it's
been a a big learning curve for me
teaching from home i can do
um councillor mrs mason
uh thank you chair firstly i'd like
to endorse the comments that you made as
chairman at the beginning of the meeting
regarding the work that
has been done by many staff members
under extremely difficult circumstances
and i'm pleased to hear the acting
managing director say that that
they have got um fatigue and
mental health alerts and they've taken
that into account
i'm sure our staff need that support
after such length of time
but i also roundly support the comments
made on the report by councillor
wilkinson
in my view the council's response to
the situation has been sub-optimal
um for example the lack of emergency
planning
demonstrates i know it's been raised
before by councillor hoy
and i believe councillor wilkinson
but here that there were no plans to
decant the office in 10 days
when emergency planning by its very
nature
should have plans to decant the office
in a day
i'm old enough to remember
when we had copious bomb scares
and they were always in the
organizations i worked for
plans to decant the office
and work from home within a matter of
hours let alone 10 days
it has been raised in this meeting
before
and i think that's something that i'm
concerned that
wasn't done but i think we've covered
that and i'm sure that the improvements
will be made in the
future um the acting manager said
there's a lot we could have done better
yeah i think there's a lot we could have
done better there's a lot we've done
very well
and we have to acknowledge that and we
also have to acknowledge where we've
failed
and where we've perhaps just fallen
short
this isn't a blame this is to find out
things that we could do better
so we should look and say what have we
done very well
what have we done badly but most
importantly what do we need to improve
and where do we need to improve to do
better
and until we accept as an organization
that we're not perfect
we do make mistakes we do fail
that improvement is going to fall
short um i would like to see
in future reports some more objective
information
and i would also like to see some
more should i say proactive um
ideas rather than reactive and again
back to girls lahore i do think that
there is
there could be an increase in
transparency but those are minor points
the major point is that
we must learn from this situation we
mustn't assume
that any criticism is negative criticism
is constructive and we should be using
it to improve
thank you thank you
councilman mrs mason i'm sure that those
your points and those of council hoy's
will be
taken into consideration and and
hopefully we'll see that
um come through in in future reports
um counselor
elton i did have you down to speak but i
can see you're no longer indicated
do you still want to speak or i wasn't
sure i remembered i'm no longer a member
of review so i didn't think i could
speak so i
i lowered my hand again thank you
so i wasn't sure if you were coming in
on a point there or a point of order
um countless bearing thank you chairman
um angela hutchins has just answered
quite comprehensively one of the issues
i was going to
raise because i believe council
wilkinson when he first spoke
touched on staff well-being but she has
subsequently highlighted
what what is being done as almost
routine procedures
now within the organization with staff
working at home so that
it's been answered also i would say um
and this is
a game with regard to the grant
situation
and it's uh passing on to businesses
uh you know from experience
i would suggest that the grants that
should have been sent out by the
district council have been
sent out promptly and efficiently it may
not always tie in with the dates
that some businesses want to receive the
money
and i know it is dependent on when the
money comes from
from government but from our experience
or my experience
this has been prompt and there has been
very little
issues with regarding to any claims
or any procedural matters so i would
just like to
to complement the council for that thank
you chairman
thank you councillor sparing um
councillor wilkinson
thank you shay um i only wanted to come
back on one very quick question actually
it was something i
picked up on from something angela was
saying um and this has been touched on
again since
so i may have misunderstood the testing
kits that were mentioned
um from south street i originally put my
hand up because
i was going to say uh whilst i accept
the course
the council officers are in south street
the vast majority of the district lives
on the western side over here
uh rayleigh uh hockley and holbridge
and obviously we need to at the time of
lockdown minimize people's travelling so
we should try and get somewhere over the
west side of the district to keep these
tests as well
that's been slightly superseded and i
may have misunderstood the answer that
she gave later to
council mcpherson's point the ground um
members helping
um and i know councilman the first one
was referring to the
the vaccinations but i know but i think
andrew also touched on members
assisting for the pc arkets as well so
um i just wanted a while's chair if i
may through you um of angela is it the
case that any member of the public that
wants a home testing kit
has to go to south street to get it um
or is there going to be
a facility for those that live in the
western side of the district to not have
to travel so far
um thank you chairman through you the um
in relation to
the home testing kits um those are
links to the uh 11 to
18 age group for school testing
you will appreciate that the
mtu the the mobile testing unit that's
based in
rayleigh um leisure uh has
seen um was put there specifically to
enable
school secondary school aged children to
be tested
uh and the original plan was that they
should be tested um
before christmas and indeed before then
returning to to school that's obviously
now subsequently being superseded
the uh home testing kits we're expecting
a
a batch of five thousand are to
supplement the work that's being done
at the uh rayleigh leisure center so
that's why it's at the
other end of the the district um the
um slots taken up at the mtu at
radiology center have been almost
exclusively 100
take up um only dipped over the
christmas new year period
um um and only then not by a significant
amount so
the demand is being met from the the
rest of the district um by the mtu
and will be then also met in the east of
the district through the
home testing kits um we are
expecting because of the demand on the
system
um and i mean by that i mean the whole
of london south
east and east of england for
the the government to require us to
continue
to provide home testing kits
which although you can still of course
um um order these
online the reliance on the
royal mail to deliver those has caused
some challenges particularly over the
holiday period and tests of course if
they're not
received by the lab um in in good time
are compromised so the idea of having
local drop-off and pick-up
areas is that they are brought by
courier
so it's our expectation that there could
very well be a follow-up
to this first 5 000 um tests and that
that more will come
and so we are actively preparing for
that eventuality and exploring
other opportunities and other sites
across the district where we could
increase
the uh availability of these of these
testing kits
um but we are wholly dependent on them
being provided to us so what we're doing
is working uh in shadow at the moment
with a view to
um being ready to mobilize if more tests
become available
thank you um i misunderstood i thought
they were for everybody i didn't realize
were just for
school this first 5 000 um council
organism
are intended to be for that age group um
because as you heard the prime minister
say yesterday those um
particular um age groups are the ones
that are the key vector for the
um the new variant of the of the viruses
things currently stand
going forward um it remains to be seen
whether government will expand that
to anybody who um who would who need to
get a test and of course
it isn't just those children aged 11 to
18 it's also their families too
okay makes perfect sense thank you
thank you angela thank you counselor
wilkinson um
councillor mrs shaw
thank you going back onto the testing
kits for the
uh school age i believe the schools have
got the testing kits also also
ready for the children when they come
back as well
uh councillor smith was saying this last
night in his school
they've already got them so they are
around the district
those um can i just come across come
back on that counselor
um mr shaw those are lateral flow test
devices and they are for um teachers and
for the children
of um key workers and vulnerable
children so children who are currently
receiving face-to-face education at
present
um the um there's a suggestion by um dfe
that going forward they'll be used for
um daily testing for children who have
been exposed
as a contact to a positive test but
these are these are not the same as the
pcr
uh swab tests which are um uh the
um postal testing kits
okay they're not the natural flow ones
yeah the school the school ones are
lateral flow the ones we're looking to
and that's that um is what the mega
center is also
distributing uh uh performing and then
our the home testing kits
are literally you come in you pick up a
kit you go home perform the test
you bring it back to the drop-off site
and it's collected
right thank you thank you for the
clarification
thank you angela thank you councillor
mrs shaw
um members haven't indicated to ask any
further questions
um we have covered this topic quite a
lot um
members that there's a on page 6.12 of
the report
paragraph 11.1 there is a recommendation
and that's for the committee to resolve
to note this report
um i hope the members will agree to note
that i think
again just to reiterate what several
councillors have
said this evening um and in particular
council wilkinson
put it very eloquently and
sympathetically that
it's it's okay to criticize but it's not
a criticism
of any individual or or anything that
has or hasn't been done this is a
learning curve for everybody
for members for staff for officers and
for the general public and i think
at the moment i think certainly in my
opinion it's clear that
we are doing a very exceptional job in
very
difficult circumstances and again our
things go to
to staff um at watchful district council
on offices
um and to end that members if
are you in agreement to note the
contents of this report and we look
forward angela to receive in future
reports
um which i'm sure will be if the content
of which will be ever
changing members it'll be an agreement
to note
the content if not can you indicate to
speak
counsel ahoy i mean obviously it's for
noting i'm
i think i would i would just like it
recorded which obviously is being
recorded
to note it that i'm noticing it but with
with reservations and i hope they're
addressed on the
next report certainly council ahoy
and council mrs mason you've indicated
as well i'm assuming
that's possibly in agreement with
councillor hawaii
council and mrs mason
sorry couldn't get the undermiter um
some reservations so i think we ought to
note with reservation
thank you council hook
yes sir chairman now i'm in agreement
with councillor
uh hawaiian councilman mrs mason
okay um i have to to be honest i think
we can note that
if we can know that those specific
members had reservations i certainly
don't at this moment in time and um i
don't know
i don't think other members do either
otherwise they would have indicated to
speak so
um i think we can note the content of
that report
and note the reservations that certain
members individual members have
thank you very much um moving on to
agenda item number seven which is the
key decisions document and hopefully
everybody has had a chance to
have a look at the key decisions uh
there are
three key decisions
um 720 the first one
disposal of the former redundant crown
hill public conveniences
i understand this report will go to the
executive in february
is that right yeah have any members got
any questions
not members but uh if i can
matt harwood white sorry it wasn't very
clear
thank you chairman um just to add on
that
point chairman i just need to um
i i'll be briefing the new portfolio
holder councillor
daniel belton uh meeting late this week
to discuss
um progress on that report it has been
delayed chairman so i need to speak with
the team and the portfolio holder to
update on the position of that
disposal of that um asset chairman uh we
had to come back to the
committee to provide a revised date
okay so just to clarify on the key
decision document it says january 2021
but
my understanding is that this is this
will be presented to the executive in
february that okay or it's anticipated
to be february it won't be february
chairman
um i wanted me to uh discuss it with the
portfolio holder first please i may okay
thank you very much
uh councillor hoy
i'm not muted i was gonna mute myself um
yeah this is something i've been
noting for a while on on on key
decisions it's been taking quite a while
and i'll see it's been pushed back again
it is something i've got
some concerns about and it's something i
would
for for warning would possibly want to
have a look at within the review
committee when it comes forward
or when the report's in a state that it
can come to the review committee
okay yep that's that's fine but
thank you for making us aware of that um
councilman mrs mason
thank you mr chairman um i haven't had
sight of the key
decisions document it's not all seniors
so therefore i've not been able to see
it so could someone
quickly briefly tell me what's on it in
case i have any concerns
um uh yep it's
um the disposal uh if i just read the
subject matter actually on the key
decision document
the heading of which is the disposal the
disposal
of former redundant crown hill public
conveniences
and it says disposal of former redundant
crown hill public convenience is subject
to marketing and granting permission
for a future leasehold agreement
and if the decision maker the executive
like i say originally on the
as stated at the moment on the report it
says january 2021 but as matt harwood
white has already pointed out that will
be delayed
no i haven't got the others yet i do
understand i understand it's on
it's under the public documents on um
cmis well i can't find it i'm on there
now
i see any access i've got i've got the
uh report
i can see officers having a look now so
if offers can just have a look at that
if you could just read out the subject
matters then i'll know if i've got a
query
okay moving on to the second item that's
on the key decision document that's
um eight forward slash 20
the subject matter title being leisure
contract
and the description underneath to agree
arrangements in respect of the leisure
contract
beyond the 2020 21 financial year
and my understanding is that that
decision has been taken
uh matt harwood why are you able to
confirm that
yeah chairman that decision was taken um
at executive in december
okay i haven't had any information on
that but i did ask
how would white a question on that about
the car parking
um perhaps you could come back to me on
that mat i don't think it's necessary to
bring it up now
perhaps you could phone me tomorrow
absolutely no problem at all
thank you thank you councillor mrs mason
thank you matt
um and the third and final
key decision is ten forward slash 20
the subject matter heading is waste
collection
and street cleaning contracts and the
description under that is
two great point of order sorry points
forward to chairman
the decisions documents they are on
their website
they're where they always are under key
decision documents
well if you can show me tell me how to
find them that's yeah thanks
i'm on the meeting okay i i can tell you
exactly where to find them
uh when you go into the original
district council
let me go back actually this is going to
take some time
this is the final one perhaps we can
reserve you can
show me another time okay it is only two
clicks to the document just to clarify
that for the future yeah
yeah yeah that's it and then you've got
um meetings but you've also got key
decisions document and they've always
been there as well
where's that on the right hand side
under the menu
it goes home committees decisions key
decisions documents
okay i think we need to just um i don't
think that's for now
um uh sorry mr chairman could you
actually
um continue because that would be
quicker and then perhaps
um an officer can explain to me what
councilman pearson is trying to explain
at a later date
yeah found yeah thank you councillor
mcpherson
for trying to help them um and thanks
mrs mason and i'm sure an officer will
be in touch
mrs mason to uh councillor mrs mason to
to give you some advice
um the third and final key decision was
10 forward slash 20.
i'll repeat the subject matter heading
was waste collection and street cleaning
contracts
and the brief description is to agree
arrangements
in respect of the waste collection and
street cleaning contracts
beyond the 2021-22
financial year and the
decision-maker obviously the executive
and date when um
or period with this decision is to be
made is february 2021
okay thank you marcus is that okay
marcus is that still on
track yes it is yes thank you
lovely thank you thank you margaret
thank you mrs ivan no other questions
so moving on to by gender item
number eight which is the work plan
and hopefully members have a chance to
review that um any questions
members on the work plan um
there are none indicated so i'll assume
i'm not trying to do my hand and i
couldn't oh sorry
no that's not probably cancer mr hoy is
um
mark's able to say when the next meeting
of the um
green space is working group is going to
happen marcus are you able to
answer that yes i guess uh i i mean um
discussion with the uh
suitable dates chair of the working
group um councillor mrs mason has had
suitable dates um
i believe we have the documentation
that's required me i think that was a
delay
i haven't i haven't seen the
documentation as you're aware
uh marcus i spoke to you but i have
asked that to be forwarded to councillor
high
and um also the minutes of course need
adjusting which i
am looking at to do but i'm having
difficulty because of the way they're
presented
again but i'm hoping to be able to sort
something out in a week's time
so so so hopefully we'll um we're going
to convene a
meeting fairly soon thank you
thank you marcus thank you council mrs
mason
and you're welcome okay
members thank you very much for your
time this evening um
we'll close the meeting now um stay safe
and well everybody
and hope to see you all